départ à la fraîche le troupeau de 250
brebis solognote prend la direction de
ces nouveaux pâturages 6 km à parcourir
encadré par une foule de curieux
invité à suivre cette transhumance le
plus discrètement possible
ça se passe très bien très très bien il
fait un petit peu chaud mais tout va
bien
les gens sont respectueux et ça va on
est dans le rythme à raison de trois
kilomètres par heure voilà le troupeau
qui arrivent comme prévu à chaumont sur
loire les brebis vont paître en bord du
fleuve sur un emplacement d'où sera tiré
en juillet le feu d'artifice quand
pâturages rime avec économie économie
pâturages c'est-à-dire économie en effet
pour les communes mais aussi pour les
bergers qui en font aussi et bien un
gagne pain et une activité parallèle de
leur activité de troupeaux pour mettre à
disposition le les troupeaux pour
entretenir les pâturages et générer des
économies pour les communes c'est un
objectif économique le soutien au
renouveau de l'agriculture mais c'est
aussi un objectif qui favorise la
transition écologique qui fait prendre
conscience aux habitants des enjeux de
la relation avec la nature
et puis c'est aussi un enjeu pour notre
économie touristique parce que c'est un
élément de l'attractivité du val de
loire
le pâturage se développe au sud de loi
sur une centaine d'hectares avec l'appui
financier des collectivités
les bergers du val de loire s'en
félicite il volonté politique ce sont
tous des mares de la et donc tous ces
espaces là ils étaient entretenus avant
mécaniquement et maintenant voilà la
biodiversité elle revient au centre des
préoccupations
donc voilà maître des moutons c'est on
va dire c'est un peu le truc à la mode
quoi donc on en profite
le cheptel pourraient atteindre à
l'avenir les 600 têtes
une bonne nouvelle pour cette race
solognote très ancienne
en déclin